نحن الان نقف داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي وهذا
قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ الذي تحول الى
نقطه اسعافات اوليه رئيسيه هذا المكان
الذي يمتلئ
بالمصابين بالاضافه الى عائلاتهم التي
نزحت من مختلف الاماكن والله الصابت في
رجلي كلت
شظايا كنت عن جامع الشمعه واقف على باب
الدار طلعت اجيب اكل ناكل انا وابن عمتي
كنا في الدار لما لقينا ه الزيفه الا في
نصنا استشهد معاي ثلاثه وانا اكلتها وزحفت
زحف وقعدت ثلاث ايام مرمي بالدار والجيران
الله يخلف عليهم جابوني ه كيف الرعايه الص
والله تمام الحمد لله والله ما قصر اقسم
بالله بوكل شغير الله محمد هي اللي بوكله
بالدنيا ما بدناش حد يزعلنا غير الله و
محمد من الزيتون من عند مجمع الشمعه من
عند مسجد
الشمعه انت مصابه ولا معك حد مصابه ابني
لقوه ملهب رجله ال اربعه ايام ما حتغير له
ابني ابني عرف ابو
عاصي الحمد لله على السلام الله يسلمك
ياما يعني لو نلتف في الاقسام المشهد
يتكرر في جميع الاقسام الكثير من هذه
الاصابات يعني لم تتلقى ال الرعايه
العلاجيه بسبب نقص الكادر الطبي بالاضافه
الى نقص يعني هلا لو ناخذ هذا المشهد
الاسره تصطف بشكل كبير جدا تصوبت في بيت
في
المدرسه على باب المدرسه ماحنا نازحين من
بيت حنون على معسكر جباليه
وتصوب وين الدول العربيه تشوفنا ايش بنعمل
احنا احنا قاعدين في المدارس امنين استشهد
ابني
واخوي خلوش لنا حدا ما ضلش حدا واخويا
وعمي ومرا عمي وبنت عمي قتلونا يا عالم يا
عالم والله قتلونا يا ناس قتلونا يا عالم
وين العال وين الدول العربيه وين الدول
الاسلاميه وين الاسلام اللي بقولوا عنه
والدين وين الدين والاسلام اللي بقولوا
عنه صف
قصفنا كيف الوضع دخل فش فيش علاجات فيش شي
في حاجه ج دود بطلع من
الجرينا دود بطلع من جرينا ما ضلش فيها يا
عالم والله ما ظل فيها يا ناس ماظل فيها
ماظل فيها الناس ماتت زي ما انت شايف
الناس مرميه تخوت ما فيش مي فيش مي نشرب
فيش اكل والله قعد ثلاث ايام جعان والله
ثلاث ايام وانا جعان والله ها مره تسالها
والله ثلاث ايام جعان الوضع ماساوي لابعد
الحدود الامكانيات
صفر فش ادويه فش ميه فش كهرباء فش ابسط
مقومات الحياه هون هيكم شايفينا على
العتمه اي طبيعي غرفه العمليات مسكره هون
بس غيار على الجرح واستقبال الولاده اللي
هي لايف سيفين بس تكون انقاذ حياه ومش
قادرين بنص الليل نحولها بنقوم
بتوليدها باقل الامكانيات يعني مع الاسف
الامكانيات اللي بنشتغل فيها كان قبل 150
سنه الصوره تتحدث بنفسها يعني كان هذا
المشهد داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي في قسم
الطوارئ والاستقبال وهو الان اصبح القسم
الرئيسي في مدينه غز
تختلف القصص لكن تلتقي الحكايات لتكون هي
الشاهده على جرم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
الصواريخ والقذائف والقناصه الاسرائيليه
التي انتشرت ما بين المدن والاذقه
والاحياء اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره
مدينه
غزه